l'italie en plein désarroi re aldo moro
suicider par les brigades rouges
il ne manque que les preuves raymond
barre devant la nouvelle assemblée une
politique est peut être un vote pour un
début de législature
les ouvriers des pays de l'est réclame
des droits véritable pour la première
fois les quatre grands syndicats sont
d'accord pour condamner la répression
des travailleurs à l'est renaud vignal
libre après huit ans de détention
un nouveau départ
là messieurs bonsoir en ce moment même
alors que la nuit tombe sur l'italie des
centaines de carabiniers sont d'un petit
lac du centre du pays à la rrq
difficilement accessibles à 16 cents 10
800 mètres d'altitude même est sous la
neige pour essayer de savoir si oui ou
non
aldo moro est mort livre al rouge
n'auront épargné aucun suspense dans ce
tragique feuilleton de l'enlèvement du
président de la démocratie chrétienne
à l'heure du déjeuner nous découvrions
en effet l'existence d'un septième
communiqué des terroristes communiqué
lapidaire que je vous lis dans son
ensemble
aujourd'hui 18 avril se termine la
période dictatorial de la démocratie
chrétienne
nous informons à cette occasion de
l'exécution de monsieur aldo mort par
suicide
son cadavre est immergé dans le lac de
la duchesse là que vous avez vus à
l'instant c'est le début dit toujours le
communiqué le début d'une longue série
de suicides qui ne doivent pas être la
seule prérogative du groupe baader
meinhof vous avez bien entendu exécuté
par suicide
l'expression est atroce reste à
confirmer bien sûr ce message dont
l'authenticité a été prouvée alors le
récit de cette journée d'angoise autres
carhaix
ce matin pourtant il y avait un espoir
un repaire des brigades rouges étaient
découverts fortuitement dans ce petit
immeuble de la vie acacias à dix
kilomètres de l'endroit où monsieur
moreau a été enlevé la cache contenait
un véritable arsenal une radio et la
machine à écrire qui a servi aux tracts
des brigades rouges et cet immeuble
n'aurait pas été la prison d'aldo moro
ce matin lorsque les policiers
interviennent c'est trop tard le
commando s'est enfui insaisissable
depuis un mois depuis le 16 mars dernier
lorsqu'un 9 heures du matin en sortant
de chez lui
aldo moro 62 ans président de la
démocratie chrétienne est enlevé par un
commando des brigades rouges et cinq
gardes du corps du président sont tués
sur le coup froidement le même jour le
gouvernement démocrate chrétien de
monsieur andreotti reçoit l'investiture
pour la première fois le parti
communiste entre dans la majorité
aldo moro avait été l'artisan de ce
rapprochement aussitôt des mesures
exceptionnelles de sécurité
compatible avec la légalité sont prises
par les cinq partis de la majorité
les milliers de policiers quadrillent
rome et se lance dans une extraordinaire
chasse à l'homme mais sans résultat deux
jours plus tard les brigades rouges
revendique l'enlèvement et font parvenir
une photo d'aldo moro
il y aura ensuite si communiqué des
brigades rouges avec des lettres de
monsieur moreau échelonnées sur un mois
il annonce un communiqué que monsieur
aldo moro est jugé par un tribunal du
peuple qu'il fait des révélations
puis il ya trois jours greffe est
condamné à mort pendant ce temps se
poursuite à turin depuis le 20 mars le
procès contre 15 des chefs historiques
des brigades rouges dont la libération
était demandée par le commando qui a
enlevé aldo moro des attentats ponctuent
ce procès est latente fièvre des
italiens mais le gouvernement malgré les
déchirements des uns des autres malgré
les appels du pape aux ravisseurs malgré
les demandes de négociations pour
raisons humanitaires de certains
journaux le gouvernement reste ferme
pas de négociation elle ce matin dont
un tract le septième des brigades rouges
indiquent aldo moro a été exécuté par
suicide et que son cadavre se trouve au
fond du lac duchesse à à 100 km de rome
oui vous avez vu le parlement italien je
vous laisse imaginer la fébrilité des
romains et des italiennes et façon
générale surtout dans les milieux
politiques complètement désorganisée par
ces péripéties à gîter à la manière de
marionnettes par les brigades rouges au
siège de l'amour est chrétienne se ne
sont qu' entré et sorti avec un certain
nombre de visite de réconfort chez
madame moreau et à une centaine de
mètres de là enrico berlinguer vient de
réunir la direction de son parti
le comité central du pc y avait
d'ailleurs suspendu pour ce faire ces
travaux avec nous maintenant de turin de
turin où sont toujours emprisonnés les
membres des brigades rouges jugés depuis
un mois victor g donc les brigades
rouges auraient diffusé leur septième
message jeudi aurait parce que sur ce
point les experts ne sont pas d'accord
d'une part il est vrai que c'est la même
machine à écrire qui a servi à composer
société message et tous les autres
messages qui ont précédé d'un autre côté
on a quand même constaté qu' il
s'agissait d'un message très court
composé seulement de 158 line alors que
d'habitude et si bien dans le style des
brigades rouges ont fait des
proclamations de fois idéologique il est
dit donc dans ce message que le corps
d'aldo moro se trouve dans le lac au
fond du lac de l'aide du chef qui se
trouvent à 45 minutes de rome les
carabiniers les policiers se sont
évidemment rendu aussitôt sur place et
ils ont constaté une chose c'est qu'il
s'agit d'une zone montagneuse très
difficile d'accès absolument désertique
et la police se demande même ce soir
comment le corps d'aldo moro aurait pu
être transportés dans ce lac autrement
qu'en hélicoptère autre chose ce lac est
encore recouverte de glace et là encore
la question se pose comment at on pu
introduire le corps d'haldimand dans un
lac qui a recouvert de glace alors ce
soir la police se demande s'il ne s'agit
pas tout simplement d'une diversion des
brigades rouges alors diversion c'est
fort possible mais si pour la police
tout cela n'est pas encore très net pour
la classe politique italienne pour la
classe dirigeante
c'est à peu près une certitude
aldo moro a été exécuté la démocratie
chrétienne est en réunion permanente
depuis ce matin il y avait depuis hier
le comité central du parti communiste
italien
les travaux du comité central ont été
suspendus et enrico berlinguer a
convoqué la direction du parti
communiste italien
pourquoi c'est que dès que il sera sur
cale de morrow a été exécuté il faudra
évidemment mobilisé il faudra organiser
des manifestations
car ce qui est important pour la classe
politique italienne c'est de montrer que
les terroristes débris à gauche sont
complètement isolés du reste de la
population italienne
il faudra le montrer dans la rue il
faudra se mobiliser véritablement alors
maintenant qu'est ce que sont ces
prisons du peuple que sont ces procès
dérisoires et bien écoutez le témoignage
d'un des patrons de fiat l'un des
premiers à avoir été enlevé il ya cinq
ans par les brigades rouges
cet homme s'appelle être ré amelio il a
62 ans
il appuie sa retraite et il vit dans un
petit village près de turin ya cinq ans
et alors qu'il était chef du personnel
du secteur automobile de fiat est avait
amerri a été enlevé par les brigades
rouges
lui aussi a été tenu prisonnier dans ce
que les brigades rouges
ap est une prison du peuple en en huit
jours
est-ce que vous pouvez vous décrire
votre lieu de détention ces fameuses
prisons du peuple pour après
l'expression les brigades rouges
yahoo piccolo images séparées
eh bien c'était un garage souterrain
divisée en deux par une cloison j'avais
à ma disposition un peu plus de trois
mètres de long et un mètre cinquante de
large
j'avais un tabouret et une petite table
les parois étaient recouvertes de
polystyrène
vous m'avez dit que vous avez été
photographiée dans quel but on vous a
photographié j'ai été photographiée
trois fois avec un polaroïd
c'est exactement le même système que
celui qui a été utilisé pour aldo moro
ces photos étaient destinés à confirmer
à la police et à la fiat que j'étais
vivant et que j'étais entre leurs mains
alors comment se dérouler les
interrogatoires
qu'est ce qu'on vous demande et que quel
genre de questions vous posez les
membres des brigades rouges
dourges tâter du bfc pas il ya eu
différentes phases en tout cas il venait
tous les jours avec des cagoules sur la
tête un peu comme le cube ce clan avec
des fentes en face des yeux il
m'interrogeais entre 2 et 4 heures par
jour au début ils m'interrogeais sur le
fonctionnement intérieur de fiat
il voulait savoir s'il y avait un
espionnage organiser s'il y avait une
police spéciale une police spéciale pour
repérer des membres des brigades rouges
chez fiat
plusieurs sympathisants six ans
peut-être avait été licencié m'ont dit
les terroristes et dire qu'à l'époque
les brigades rouges relâcher leur otage
aujourd'hui il es tu alors dans l'espoir
d'une issue moins tragique monsieur
moreau les appels à la clémence continue
à monter d'un peu partout dans le monde
ne tuez pas ne tuez plus écrit le
quotidien du vatican l'osservatore
romano
amnesty international a elle aussi lancé
un appel à la non violence
jimmy carter a fait savoir au
gouvernement italien qui prit ainsi que
tout le peuple américain cours de van
damme le secrétaire général de l'onu
lance un nouvel appel désespéré pour la
libération de monsieur moreau et raymond
barre à l'instant après avoir rencontré
le président république en fin
d'après-midi a évoqué le drame italien
j'espère que la vie de l'eau chaude
moreau est parvenu que la nouvelle n'est
pas exact en tout cas ce tragique pour
la démocratie alors à tout moment
évidemment s'il se passe quelque chose
dans ce journal nous manquons paraît de
toute façon pour marquer l'événement
toute l'équipe du journal d'antenne 2 se
déplacera cette semaine à rome et vous
présentera une grande partie nos
informations en direct de la capitale
iter et puis demain les journalistes de
cette chaîne vous présenterons un
document que vous serez les premiers à
avoir un document passionnant sur ce qui
se passe au cambodge
vous savez que depuis la libération
entre guillemets d'autonomes peine ya
quatre ans nous n'avons jamais pu filmer
une seule image de la capitale
cambodgienne
mais demain soir dans le cadre notre
magazine à 21h30
vous pourrez voir un document
exceptionnel qui a été ramené par nos
confrères de la télévision yougoslave à
document qui se passe de commentaires je
vous laisse simplement voir l'atmosphère
lugubre des rues de phnom penh une
capitale dont tous les habitants sans
exception ont été déportés à la campagne
par les autorités
souci
-
donc pas une âme qui vive dans les rues
de phnom penh donc je vous le répète ne
ratez pas ce rendez vous demain soir sur
le cambodge 21h30 la sphère française
maintenant quinze jours après son
installation officielle la nouvelle
assemblée nationale n'a commencé ses
travaux aujourd'hui avec une série de
questions d'actualité posées aux membres
du gouvernement n'a remarqué beaucoup de
questions de nouveaux députés neuf ans
tout me dit daniel brême et puis ensuite
l'examen du projet de loi qui prévoit
une augmentation de la quote-part de la
france au fmi le fonds monétaire
international
le groupe socialiste a déposé une
question préalable à l'encontre de ce
projet les communistes eux ont fait
appel à une autre procédure
mais cela ne devrait pas empêcher
l'adoption de ce projet de loi dans la
nuit en fait cette journée n'aura été
qu'un apéritif 6 cuillères pour les
députés
le grand débat c'est celui de demain sur
la politique économique de raymond barre
avec toujours cette inconnue le
gouvernement posera tine ou non la
question de confiance
tout laisse indiquer que oui mais on ne
le saura que demain au sortir du conseil
des ministres le premier ministre est
nommé par le président de la république
mais il est responsable devant
l'assemblée nationale
celle ci peut renverser le gouvernement
en votant une motion de censure le
gouvernement lui-même peut engager sa
responsabilité devant l'assemblée
on utilise encore souvent une expression
ancienne le gouvernement dit on pose la
question de confiance
si le gouvernement à l'occasion d'une
déclaration de politique générale engage
sa responsabilité
le débat se termine par un vote auquel
tous les députés doivent prendre part si
les votes négatifs sont plus nombreux
que les votes positifs le gouvernement
est amené à démissionner si le
gouvernement n'engage pas sa
responsabilité sur sa déclaration de
politique générale
l'opposition peut déposer une motion de
censure seul vote les députés qui sont
favorables à cette motion est celle ci
est adopté s'il obtient la majorité
absolue des membres de l'assemblée
nationale le premier ministre peut aussi
engagé sa responsabilité sur le vote
d'un texte ce texte est considéré comme
adopté sauf si une motion de censure est
votée
boehler philippe sassier à dévoiler ici
même hier soir une partie d'une
intention de monsieur bart mais il nous
faut maintenant savoir quels sont les
moyens qui seront à sa disposition pour
la première fois depuis bien longtemps
ce n'est pas un ministère de l'économie
et des finances qui va répondre à ses
désirs mais deux ministères celui de
l'économie et celui du budget alors
pourquoi ce démantèlement
la réponse est allé claude le véritable
pouvoir en france il est sans doute ici
derrière ses murs car dans les bureaux
des bâtiments plus chargé d'histoire que
vraiment fonctionnel il ya des hommes
très puissant ici rue de rivoli et dans
les 3000 immeubles en france qui
dépendent du ministère il y à 170 mille
fonctionnaires ils collectent l'argent
il réglemente il contrôle
il s'occupe de vous de moi par les
impôts bien sûr mais aussi des
commerçants et de toutes les activités
des entreprises françaises concrètement
se représentait disons quelqu'un qui
était juge et partie vous donnerez un
exemple prenez un caissier dans une
entreprise
imaginez ce caissier qui aurait petit à
petit débordé sur ses prérogatives et
qui aurait finalement atteint le grade
ou il assumerait la direction générale
d'une entreprise c'est un petit peu
grossièrement ce qui s'est passé avec le
ministère des finances dans quel domaine
vous avez affaire à lui bien finalement
dans des domaines un petit peu inattendu
nous avons affaire à lui
par exemple nous exportons notre
entreprise exporte à peu près 50% son
chiffre d'affaires on pourrait
s'imaginer que l'interlocuteur
lorsque que nous exportons soit le
ministère du commerce extérieur
eh bien non dans beaucoup de cas nous
avons affaire au ministère de l'économie
et des finances car le ministère de
l'économie et des finances tient les
cordons de la bourse et donc détermine
les crédits qui sont faits à
l'exportation et c'est donc avec lui
qu'on négocie fréquemment et
l'entreprise ne sont qu'un exemple le
pouvoir de la rue de rivoli et
tentaculaire cela va des impôts aux
services de la loterie nationale en
passant par des domaines aussi divers
que la monnaie les douanes ou encore
l'imprimerie nationale
dorénavant donc le ministère sera coupée
en deux d'un côté rené monory ministre
de l'économie il aura en quelque sorte
la conception
de l'autre côté ce sera la gestion avec
maurice papon ministre du budget est ce
une révolution il est sûrement trop tôt
pour le dire car cela dépendra de la
volonté politique de faire aboutir la
réforme mais aussi de la résistance de
l'administration elle-même
c'est une réforme en tout cas bien
accueillie par les chefs d'entreprise il
faudrait que le ministère de l'économie
et des finances où le ministère
maintenant du budget puis déterminer les
grandes lignes de l'économie et du
développement industriel de la france et
aux chefs d'entreprise d'assumer leurs
propres responsabilités et de gérer
librement leurs entreprises cela sera
d'autant plus facile que nous
retrouverions la liberté des prix qui
nous a été confisquée il ya bientôt 30
ans l'accueil plutôt favorable des
entreprises tient peut-être plus à la
personnalité du ministre de l'économie
rené monory ancien chef d'entreprise lui
même n'a jamais caché sa préférence pour
la liberté des prix en tout cas cette
réforme devrait si elle est effective
lever une des ambiguïtés de la politique
française
celle qui rendait parfois le ministre
des finances plus puissant que le
premier ministre lui même
et puis je vous indique que tout le
débat de politique générale du
gouvernement sera retransmis en direct
sur cette chaîne donc demain après midi
le syndicat libre des travailleurs du
rss en lisant ceci que l'on croit rêver
et pourtant un certain nombre d'ouvriers
soviétique essaie de tout faire pour lui
donner une existence à paris ce matin
quatre ouvriers des pays de l'est ont
voulu dénoncer les entraves à la liberté
syndicale qu'ils subissent dans leur
pays
trois d'entre eux ont été expulsés ou
ont dû s'exiler le quatrième a bénéficié
d'un visa et compte revenir
prochainement roumanie et pour la
première fois depuis bien longtemps on a
vu les quatre principaux syndicats
français côte à côte
la cgt la cfdt force ouvrière et la
scène côte à côte dans gq pour apporter
leur soutien à ce travail
quelles sont vos impressions et le suivi
sont variés comme le mouvement ouvrir
même comme la situation dans ce pays
provenant le
le plus dangereux situation et en union
soviétique où on ferme les gens dans les
prisons psychiatrique sacchi d'un très
inquiétant que ce ce seul une nouvelle
forme de répression
par exemple en pologne
les autorités produits profitent des
expériences de l'argentin et des brasil
et utilise méthodes et gangsters de plus
hier ouvriers membres de ce mouvement
ont été battus le dernière et semaine en
pologne voilà la situation quand même
pire en turquie ou en roumanie où les
mouvements n'est pas aussi puissant et
qu'en pologne là bas on met dans les
prisons on expulse dutrey du travail
c'est un tueur se maquille surtout c'est
qu'un trait monsieur part à ce qu'ils
avaient annoncé votre intention de
retourner en roumanie
quels sont les risques pour vous courez
le camarade ceausescu a déclaré qu'on ne
pouvait pas résoudre les problèmes en
fuyant de son pays mais en y restant
pour contribuer tous ensemble à
l'édification d'une vie meilleure pour
tous alors serait ce au nom de nouveau
victimes de la répression
c'est justement la réponse à cette
question qui informera l'opinion
publique mondiale sur la manière dont
notre président tient ses engagements en
bref toujours l'étranger fin d'examen de
conscience de jimmy carter à l'occasion
du séminaire de cannes david avec cette
étonnante confession rapportés par le
porte-parole de la maison blanche
le présent carter n'a pas exercer
pleinement ses pouvoirs mais nous allons
mieux faire les choses je vous rappelle
que prétend américain était très
inquiète de la baisse de sa popularité
suite du voyage de cours de valdes am au
proche-orient le secrétaire général de
l'onu a passé la journée au sud liban
le gouvernement libanais lui a demandé
plus de casques bleus dans cette région
temple et puis à partir de demain
un congrès qui devrait être passionnant
en espagne celui du parti communiste là
bas comme ici plusieurs tendances
s'affrontent mais les proportions de la
contestation sont beaucoup plus grande
de l'autre côté des pyrénées
beaucoup de militants proches en effet à
santiago carillo l'abandon de certains
dogmes du parti communiste
barcelone les catalans préparent leur
participation au congrès du parti
communiste espagnol santiago carillo
écoute parler la base et dans ce débat
qui se déroule au grand jour on
s'aperçoit vite le carillon au pape de
l'eurocommunisme ne fait pas l'unanimité
propose-t-il d'abandonner le terme
léninisme dans les statuts du parti de
ne plus accepter d'autres figures de
proue que celle du marxisme et donc de
faire concorder les statuts avec la
réalité euros communiste du pce
les militants s'entredéchirent sans
avoir peur de révéler leurs
contradictions et le nom bien souvent
l'emportent sur le wii et ses pingouins
tradition il ya des camarades qui
estiment le contraire
on discute lé congrès va la suivre c'est
une péripétie pour vous mais cette vigne
des péripéties des parts nous pas eu
beaucoup de péripéties que dépassé damon
est ce que ça veut dire que le
secrétaire général du parti communiste
espagnol est aujourd'hui contestée par
sa base il est habile en qui il
partie de notre parti qui conteste
disposition ça c'est évident et vous
vous y attendiez qui m'attendait oui il
y est bien posé ces questions m'enchante
régnant que ça allait provoquer une
grande discussion une contestation du
parti vais de mon parti mais parce que
les loyers que c'est nécessaire
peut-être l'histoire se souviendra tel
de ce congrès comme de celui qui pour la
première fois s'est préparé en pleine
lumière démocratiquement dit on ici
mais aujourd'hui l'espagne ne voient en
lui que le congrès de la contestation du
dedans et du dehors projet samsun
l'ancien militant envoyé spécial de
carillo en espagne au moment de la
clandestinité
exclu du parti en 64 à délaisser
quelques temps son oeuvre de scénariste
pour publier ses mémoires de militants
mémoire qui placent santiago carillo en
position d'accusé
je crois qu'on ne peut pas d'une façon
je ne parle pas même pas de morale qu'on
ne peut pas politiquement se présenter
en champion de l'eurocommunisme de la
rénovation démocratique du monde
communiste
si on ne fait pas ce même travail dans
la mémoire et dans l'histoire du parti
qu'on reprenne vous reprocher un peu à
carillo d'avoir oublié qu'il a été salie
nist je leur reproche non pas seulement
d'avoir oublié mais de prétendre le
contraire
vous dites qu'il n'est plus marxiste
parti communiste espagnol est en train
d'abandonner le terme léninisme
difficilement mais en train quand même
oui qu'est ce qu'il reste d'un parti
communiste qu'il est plus marxiste ni
nevin il reste sur la vérité de du parti
communiste d'espagne tels que tel que se
dessine son avenir dans la mesure où je
crois que les thèses de carillo finiront
par s'imposer dans le parti je crois
qu'il n'y a pas la possibilité
aujourd'hui que qu'il soit si vous
voulez renverser
disons que c'était soit battu au congrès
il reste un grand parti social-démocrate
de type nouveau contesté à moscou et à
madrid
un an après c'est l'égalisation alors
pourtant que la gauche espagnole
recouvre chaque jour un peu plus sa
place c'est le congrès du doute que le
pce s'apprête à tenir
promise pour la première fois il ya
quelques heures du prix de la fondation
aymeric simon lorière la mémoire de
l'ancien jeune député du var le prix a
été attribué au laboratoire de recherche
pour la réinsertion professionnelle des
handicapés à paris les statistiques qui
font froid dans le dos publié par le
ministère l'intérieur pour l'année 76
près de deux millions de crimes et
délits en tout genre là dessus plus de
16000 à faire des affaires de moeurs de
moeurs pardon donc 15 cents viols les
statistiques donc je vous déclare son il
y a deux ans de 67
la fiancée canadienne de jacques mesrine
interpellé hier à paris en plein palais
de justice
bravant les lois françaises qui l'avait
expulsé à la suite d'une condamnation à
20 ans de prison
elle voulait un permis de communiquer
pour revoir son ami et vous voyez là
l'amour était plus fort que la liberté
et à la verse une affaire qui se finit
bien
en tout cas provisoirement celle de rené
vignal tous les sportifs ont relevé lors
elle il s'agit bien de l'ancien gardien
de but de l'équipe de france condamné à
15 ans de réclusion pour des hold-up est
mise en liberté conditionnelle depuis ce
matin
après huit ans de détention dans sa
prison renée vignol vous le voyez ici
entraîner l'équipe de foot des détenus
ces images il va essayer d oublier
il a retrouvé la liberté aujourd'hui à
7h dans le matin gris et pluvieux de la
haute garonne
rené vignal ce n'était pas un détenu
comme les autres et s'il faut bien
rappeler aujourd'hui ce qui l'a conduit
en cellule on ne peut oublier l' idole
qu'il était pour des millions de
français passionné de football
gardiens de but de l'équipe de france
dix sept fois sélectionné renée vignol
était surnommé le goal volant dans le
monde entier hélas quand une mauvaise
fracture sonne pour lui l'heure de la
retraite il ne réussit pas sa
reconversion de champion il devient
gangster avec sa bande
baptisé le gang des pères de famille il
commet 27 holder de 69 à 61 il y a deux
ans roger couderc l'avait rencontré en
prison
vignal a plus de 50 ans avait alors
regretté sa déchéance
le sport avait beaucoup donné mais aussi
il m'a plu beaucoup c'est à dire qu'à
l'âge de 27 28 ans que j'étais au sommet
de démagogie sportive
il m'est arrivé des pépins familiaux et
d'équipements ce que j'ai divorcé depuis
après j'étais bien ici que j'ai déjà été
baissée c'est là que tout est parti
comme j'avais un peu d'argent j'ai
commencé à fréquenter les bars c est l
escalade
est-ce que vous vous sentez maintenant
guéries la vie on aime bien moi oui je
crois que pour moi c'est terminé
d'abord parce que je suis conscient que
j'ai produit un président un préjudice
moral on y est ordinaire je serais
vraiment un sale mec si je pouvais
revenir un jour en faire des bêtises
parce que j ai vraiment hâte pour un
égoïste et tant que ça je souhaite c'est
ma famille qui est même énormément qui
me soutient comment on peut se souvenir
vraiment des gars alors je crois que
vraiment pour moi je terminais depuis
quand mais aussi il faut pas oublier que
j'ai bientôt 50 ans que je sais pas
quand je vais sortir mais après je serai
plus un tout jeune ordre du que je n'ai
plus le droit de faire des conneries
son père excuses de solutions vous
sentez la vie parce que vous me disiez
lorsque je suis rentré en prison ou
santé du village salle bien sûr mais je
crois que il ya plus on peut avoir honte
d'avoir visage ça mais on peut avoir
beaucoup plus lente si on reste sur nos
gardes
c'était il ya deux ans rené vignal est
donc aujourd'hui libéré
conditionnellement un mot encore sur la
marée noire avant de conclure plusieurs
nappe menace maintenant l'île de sein
mais comme je vous le disais hier soir
les vents se sont orientés au secteur
sud ouest et ont tendance à éloigner la
marée noire des côtes du nord est du
finistère ses ventes continuons
d'ailleurs à souffler dans la même
direction de demain reste aussi le
problème du stockage on entrepose un peu
partout et surtout un peu n'importe
comment
tous ces résidus mazoutés et une réunion
aura lieu demain à paris pour trouver
une solution à ce problème
la météo maintenant pour le reste du
pays une météo assez pessimiste qui
prévoit un temps très nuageux sur la
majeure partie du pays
des pluies modérées sur le nord-est et
des averses accompagnées de neige et
d'orages sur le sud-est sur la moitié
ouest du pays maintenant alternance
d'averses et d'éclaircies
avant de vous quitter je crois qu'il
faut faire un point très rapide sur les
recherches
la sphère aldo moro lauriane vient
d'être interrompue puisqu'elles n'ont
donné aucun résultat ils ont été
interrompues en raison de l'obscurité
qui règne dans la partie montagneuse où
l'on cherche le col d'aldo moro et les
enquêteurs pensent à une diversion
possible de la part des brigades rouges
il ya de toute façon donc eu davantage
de nouvelles après les dossiers de
l'écran vers 23h30 avec gérard holtz qui
vous présentera la dernière édition
il est temps pour moi de prendre congé
maintenant je vous retrouve demain avec
plaisir bonsoir à tous